hey good morning London Wow usually I
have like a little time like set up my
laptop but it's already set up silent I
guess we're just gonna go from here huh
hi I'm Ken wheeler it's can't underscore
wheeler on tour That's not me that came
with keynote you kept it and yeah so my
talking his performance is magic and I
guess we could start with what is magic
and I'm very sorry I know this is the
land of Mary Poppins and Hogwarts and
what-have-you but it is not real sorry
magic I guess defined by whatever
dictionary on Google came up first is
illusions as entertainment by the use of
sleight of hand sleight of hand which is
basically trickery and it's absolutely
everywhere in UI programming as you can
see in this incredibly unmaintained
carousel right it looks like you're just
yeah you can go infinite go back around
it's all smooth
okay how does that work and you know it
is just trickery right when you come
here and you take the overflow off
that's what yeah just depending ones to
the other side it's just a collection of
filthy rotten tricks so filthy rotten
tricks as they relate to performance
normally when you have a performance
talk what you're seeing or suggestions
for things like service workers are you
lazy loading images code splitting all
that stuff and I guess a lot of the
focus that I see is on low time
performance right everybody wants their
site to load up on bed networks or what
have you you know network conditions
that are less than favorable and the big
metric that I guess they always focus on
you
is time to interactive here see you here
well feedback so what is interactive
interactivity is when your main thread
has gone idle post loading and it's the
point at which users can actually use
your app so instead of talking about the
load stuff which you know there's
there's a lot of prescriptive stuff you
can do today I'm going to talk about
runtime performance
once you've become interactive staying
there sorry no drum machines today so
how do you know if you have a
performance problem to be honest most of
the time you don't if you if you do have
a performance problem it's usually
pretty apparent otherwise right if you
do if you have a performance problem at
your app works fine not really a problem
you know until it till it becomes one
but you know it's not a huge problem and
you know you shouldn't optimize
prematurely for problems you don't have
but if you do see it the first sign of a
performance problem is jank
and what jank I guess the the technical
term for jank the definition is a
perceptible pause and the smooth
rendering of a software applications
user interface due to slow operations or
poor interface design right
so if we see jank if our stuff looks
like it sucks the first place that we
want to go is dev tools all right now
going into this right like usually I
build like robot crossbows and drum
machines and I'm pretty sure not a lot
of people have that much domain
knowledge there but coming here today I
didn't know how familiar people were
with this particular panel here if you
feel comfortable in here can I see can I
see a show of hands who feels
comfortable in this panel all righty
cool I'll proceed with that knowledge
yeah so this is your performance tab
right and that is the record button and
and here is where you discover where the
jank is coming from this right here is
gross this is like the worst case
scenario this isn't just jank this is
full main thread lockup
if we look at these arrows right that
rascal up top that's your frame rate
that when it's um when it's all green
and I have a cursor you see the cursor
yeah so this green right here this is
this is money we're having a good time
and then right here you've dropped to
zero everything stopped
not just animations but all your
interactivity and but you're seeing down
here is a long-running task right this
is two and a half seconds of main thread
lockup where your animation stole your
users can't click buttons it's a bad
place to be right so two and a half
seconds obviously sucks but you know
what what are the acceptable limits
right
google has this thing called the rail
performance model response animation
idle and low and I don't care about idle
and yeah not that I don't care about
load we're just not gonna talk about
that today but for response and
animation animation you have 16
milliseconds right which is an animation
frame so you have 16 milliseconds to do
your business and if you go over that
you drop animation frames now if you're
just doing like an update to something
right you're generally alright with drop
frames the problem with with actual like
linear animations is is that your user
kind of knows where you're going with it
right if this thing is animating over to
here right there's a reasonable
expectation that if it's moving at this
speed like sideways and it stops and
like right they can see that because
they're expecting it to be here and so
you have to be particularly careful with
animations as far as response right if
somebody clicks something and you get
feedback from clicking something the
rule here is 100 milliseconds right if
you've ever seen the superhuman mail
thing
they use this quote a lot that every
interaction should be faster than 100
milliseconds it's the the threshold
where things feel instantaneous there's
a couple schools of thought here that
it's 100 milliseconds other people say
50 milliseconds but if you aim for that
your app will feel fast right so if if
neither those marks are on or and how do
we fix it right and the hard part about
this and largely runtime performance in
general is that unlike a lot of the
advice you can give out about like you
know making your site service workers
also that it's not super prescriptive
right when you have a performance
problem it's like a it's like a puzzle
that you have to figure out and
sometimes you have to get creative and
that's largely what I'm here to talk
about today all right
and I have this thing called the aam
dope system really just the bullet
points lined up but if you have a
performance problem right you'll
identify that it exists and this is the
most important part measure your timings
right you want to you want to measure
these things not just to get an idea of
how slow it is but if you actually take
down the actual measurements and then
you improve them then you have hard
metrics right so if you go to your boss
and you're like hey the problems fixed
alright they're like yeah great that's
awesome but if you're if you come at
them with like hard data you're like it
is like 2.7 three times faster then I
guess it's better from an individual
marketing perspective wow you've really
done it now we like so after that right
you're gonna develop a plan based upon
what the what the problem is
you know you develop a plan on how to
solve it and then from there you open
dev tools and screw around and iterate
and and fix and measure and fix and
measure and until it's within an
acceptable limit and then you enjoy your
newly performant app so the most
important part measuring it let's talk
about that right now so this is one of
the most beautiful things in the entire
world this is
in animation running at 60 frames per
second it's gorgeous
if you don't know what you're looking at
right here this is one frame right
that's that's a that's one animation
frame 16 milliseconds and you can see
down here the work that we're doing is a
very small part of that right this is
very fast running so it has room to do
other things like handle user input etc
if you look at it up close this is what
that that little blip looks like right
you have the animation frame fired our
actual function call which is the thing
that we are doing is you know eighty
microseconds which is lovely that's
that's a good place to be and then you
have some other browser stuff over here
so that can often be I guess hard too
hard to read so there's a thing called
user time he says anybody seen these
things right here right if you use react
right you'll see these in your dev tools
pretty often and what that is is it's an
API that lets you define precise
performance markings and you can name
them and display them in dev tools and
especially if you're if you have some
really complicated stuff going on trying
to track down what exactly is the
problem is difficult
so using this let you kind of isolate
what you care about measure specific
things right here right oh geez I
thought I could click on it yeah so you
call performance mark and then you give
it like a string name and you do
expensive things in here or you know
whatever you're necessarily measuring
and then here you do performance that
mark me and thread stop and then
performance that measure and then give
that a name and the second and third
arguments are the the two marks and then
it'll show up there just like this right
in your timings it says main thread
right there so if you want to measure
specific things it's super helpful and
react kind of has that built in for
something so if you see the react ones
with the little react emoji deal that's
what that is
and we'll show a little bit of that so
with that said I want to talk about some
some common problems
that you might have and the solution of
those problems right with the caveat
that there is no such thing it's magic
and again there's there's nothing there
it's like hey this will just make my up
fast right let's let's do this
everywhere
everything has a trade-off every
performance optimization you're gonna
make has some kind of trade-off so you
know you only want to use it when
applicable when you actually have a
problem and not prematurely optimize
your app so let's talk about react first
I guess that's appropriate right yeah so
most of the performance problems I see
with react are related to unnecessary
rendering and it's it's kind of wild how
many people that that I say like what
I'm like working with people or
interviewing people things like that
that think that react somehow optimizes
the renders but it doesn't right if
something changes an apparent right it's
gonna render everything unless told to
do otherwise so if you're having a
performance problem a lot of time what
you can do is control those renders now
one thing about react is it is not great
when you have a lot of things or
entering at the same time and that's
being nice about it so you have to work
around that what helps with this is
another level of dev tools here which is
like the best thing this is the react
dev tools profiler can I see a show of
hands who actually uses this awesome
this is like the best thing I worked at
a lot of people who you know either do
like systems languages or they work in
in UI stuff that's not on the web and
they see this I show them I'm like
alright let's just look into whatever
the problem is and I look and they're
like whoa like your guys's dev tools
stuff is out of control and I like yeah
kind of things it is it's nice over here
so this is the this is the profiler
button right here if you have an
installed you'll see you right there and
then you can hit this little record
rascal over here and then you can start
interacting with your your react app and
what it's going to do is it's gonna keep
track of all the things that rendered
why they rendered
all kinds of super useful information
right
so famous last words let's optimize the
react tab you can I can I go on my
second screen I have to get out of this
geez I thought I could just swipe over I
guess not
Kenny's talk demos alright so here we
have a react thing that doesn't really
do much it just renders a bunch of
stupid tiles you can click I'm on and
off and let's just let's just take an
initial look geez I might dock this
alright so you can you can press this
one to reload and start profiling if you
wanna get the initial render so we can
go and then hit stop okay so get this is
like the most annoying bar get that out
of there and go to rank and we can see
each one of these tile things rendered
no just to see what we're actually doing
here I'll slide over to this yeah so
this is a house font size okay pretty
good okay yeah so here right we have our
initial state where I do filthy array
tricks to generate this or this bunch of
tiles that is the state here I have a
tile component that will render the the
tile we also have a console.log that'll
say that it's rendered strangely no lint
error and then here in our app right we
kind of just render these out state
tiles ma'am
etc and then when you click one it's
gonna go through here and it's gonna set
that one active right we have our state
with our use date so let's head back
over here for a second so we look over
here and we see that this is has
rendered and you see over here once you
click it this is like the best thing
ever it says why did this render and
says this is the first time this
component rendered that's fair
so if we start profiling again and then
we click something and then stop all
right so only one of these tiles changed
however all of them re-rendered and that
sucks only the one that changed should
render all right so let's find out what
happened here let's go through oh my
goodness hooks changed props changed
jeez Louise right so it tells you prop
change on click and children all right
so let's see what's going on here so one
of the first things we can do here is
for our our tile component we can wrap
it with a memo all right and this is
your hooks equivalent of should
component update or a pure component
right where this will not rerender if
your props or state has not changed so
we'll hit save the hot reload action Wow
do it again they're still rendering Wow
so this one the prop change active
that's valid but on click and children
also changed the rest of these just on
click and children change so let's see
what's going on here
so here right we have this this this
handle click business here you have your
on click prop that gets passed these
Rascals right here so one thing that we
can do is in here and say you know Const
click handler equals use callback
alright so this will memorize this
callback here wait
yeah yeah I think we're good alright
alright let's see if that fixed it
I hate live coding so much all right
not fixed yet I mean unclick change
well that's BS oh sorry I'm dumb we want
to do it here
because it's coming down from the top so
here I can say well we better update
that or we're gonna have a problem want
to do it down here so here we'll say
clickhandler
all right and then that's getting past
in that call is that right go back
eating up the clock here all right
I still changed hidden hmm what what's
the second argument we're gonna do this
aren't we
gotta love those hooks am i right hooks
API reference Oh
nobody knows how to [ __ ] use hooks
myself included
alright so now children is the last one
so this kind of still kind of sucks
right so yeah that does suck so we're
gonna have the children get recreated
each time right because we're passing it
a child that gets JSX right there so
here I could do something I could say
like name is equal to tile name right
and then just come back up into tile
here and you can take name and children
name take name out of there come here do
a little thought it would self close now
that's what I'm talking about right
there
only the only the one changed so if we
go here and let's just do it from from
scratch or real quick it does the first
one and then we do this right here you
can see there's there's there's two
things right here if I go to rank again
this is our first one right which has
them all on initial render and then we
come here on the click right and it's
just because props changed active all
right so yeah just to review what went
there all right we put a memo on our
tile then when we passed in the click
handler we use the react to use callback
to cache and memorize this callback
function here which what other guy
otherwise get created every single time
and then we took the
the child of this and moved it right up
into here and now my stupid title thing
is performing it's a good good thing god
[ __ ] hooks ok so yeah the next thing
we're you gonna see a lot of problems
right our lists
so as developers um almost everything
that we do is building elaborate lists
of [ __ ] I'm not kidding think about it
look at all the apps look at everything
you work on look at all the apps on your
phone there are all just lists lists
with you know actions and things like
that but you know they're just lists so
lists can become a problem right I this
is a Canon wheeler quote is it generally
speaking they should be virtualized what
will happen is if you have a list where
you know how long it is alright and it's
not that long you're good to go right
but if you're if you're getting a list
and populating it from the server
alright a lot of time you said oh it'll
it'll never be twenty thousand things
and then they put it on to prod data and
boom it's twenty thousand things and
they're slow so get ahead of that
what virtualization is is uh thank addy
Osmani for the sick graphics so I was
gonna make this myself you have this
little window right here and what it
does is it says if you have a really
long list of things alright only render
the [ __ ] that's inside of that window
right easy enough right so it does suck
from time to time and I'll tell you why
certain virtualized implementations
right you can't like control F search it
that's something I'm dealing with now
right somebody's like searching on the
page right if it doesn't exist if it's
not rendered right your your control f
and your browser isn't going to find it
so you know you do what any developer
worth their salt does an override
control F in the browser write a custom
fine that that always works at best
right they also introduced challenges to
accessibility which sucks
you can we rounded sometimes if you do
the right key bindings on it or you know
progressive progressively D Hance also
sometimes if you have like heavy
rendering in your list if your list is
like super fancy sometimes it'll show
like flashing if your rendering can't
keep up with the the windowing so if you
want to virtualize your lists to make
them better you can use things this is
my personal favorite right now which is
react window by the lovely Brian Vaughn
he also wrote react virtualized which
give you a little bit more right if
you're trying to do like a grid or a
data table kind of thing there's also
iron lists if you're one of those folks
that uses web components so let's take a
look at how lists go close this tab of
Shame
alright so this is a regular a regular
ash list right if we go look at the the
code for this it's nothing nothing
special right in here I just generate
10,000 loose items and then here I just
dump them in to the Dom right if we want
to look at some some profiling here we
can take a look alright not too bad
right so it's a little crappy on the
first render not super bad right
the problem is when you do it in react
right so if you do this in react it
becomes horrible because each one is
wrapped to the react component and then
gets processed by the reconciler
but it's let's do a refresh one here
wowie absolutely heinous gross
gross how long did that take these are
the the user timings by the way ain't
the list amounts takes 334 milliseconds
so let's look at some interactivity here
I want to hit that look look see see it
frees everything up alright if you want
to reverse that list and then reconcile
that and react that one
come here Wow so this is our our actual
interaction right here and it's it's
committing host effects 10,000 total
that's gross and you don't want to do
that
so I'll show you virtualized here right
used react window for this demo if you
come in here you import your your lists
from react window we have our same thing
right here it's pretty straightforward
you have this this list component you
have to give it a height and a width and
an item size and then the children are
kind of like a function but you can kind
of just give it a component use of hooks
so here I can have a I can have ro call
memo on it you get index style and data
style gives it like the absolute
positioning that'll put it where it
needs to be and then I can say for my
data right which is list items the index
of that data that I want to render right
so that's the array index so if we head
back and go to the virtualized Edition
check out how blazing fast that is Wow
we and it just scrolls perfect pretty
fast to you like if you don't there's
not too much of leaching if you add a
bunch of stuff in here there's took a
while to render you might see a little
bit of glitching but it's a pretty
simple list so go check out our
performance metrics
and that's much better right I don't see
a I don't see any read at all yeah so
that that's list virtualization let's
make it count okay Jesus
okay so the next thing I wanna talk
about is CPU intensive tasks from time
to time you might have to do something
kind of heavy in the browser right
unfortunately all of our code runs on
the main thread and that's where your UI
usually runs so that sucks
yes if you do anything that CPU
intensive and you lock up that main
thread like we did initially everything
stops the way to fix that is with web
workers and I see in show hands who
actually uses web workers not enough
because web workers like the best thing
seriously it's amazing right I've solved
a lot of performance issues with web
workers because they create a thread
right it's a background thread for the
web where your code can run off of the
main thread freeing that up to do the
important UI work the problem with them
I guess you know you know why it's you
might not run to it for every problem is
it talking to it back and forth right
you have to serialize whatever you're
sending over so there's cases where
that's not worth it it just doesn't make
sense if you wanted to create one right
you would have this you create like a
worker jeaious and then you say worker
equals new worker you set up a listener
here look for the for the on message so
you say when it gets a message when it
sends a message to the main JavaScript
just console.log bat and then here I
send a message to it I say go do stuff
and then in worker right there's there's
the listener here for on message and
when this gets this message it sends a
message back right so you toss in a
potato around here and eventually this
will render it did stuff but I guess the
point of this is that it executes on a
background thread and I'll show you a
cool example of that so if we look at
our code here
all right I have a some canvas stuff
going on here
hey there's gonna be a box that's good
doing something here and then in here so
we have the main thread button so in
here I want to call this calculate
primes method for the main thread button
which is gonna run an expensive thing
over here I'm gonna have it in a worker
and we're just gonna send a post message
to that worker if we look at the worker
here I'm doing the same thing that I was
doing this time just in the worker so if
we head over here and go to our worker
demo this is a beautiful 60 frames per
second animation when I hit the main
thread everything stops stops it so sad
but we do it in a worker it keeps going
and keep clicking it you click it a
billion times nobody cares it's fine
your stuffs all set so if you have a
heavy CPU tasks you can do that there if
you have non-network long running tasks
or not no it's a lot of time right if
you if you if you click a button in your
responses and fast enough right a lot of
time that's the server if it's not the
server it's your actual code you're
actually doing computation how do we
make that faster if we can't you know if
our JavaScript isn't fast enough how do
we make it faster by not writing
JavaScript my writing was um so was a
funny one it's an open standard that
defines a portable binary code format
for executable programs right despite
being called webassembly right it's it's
not really web I mean it runs on the web
but it's it's it's own thing and what it
is it's a compilation target for things
like C C++ rust a couple different
languages where you can do some some
wild stuff on the web with and if you're
doing really computationally heavy
things you can do it in awesome the
downsides are you know
has to be worth it right like you're not
just gonna add two numbers together with
wasum then JavaScript's gonna be faster
but if you're like putting an xbox game
in the browser not only is it faster
than javascript javascript couldn't do
it all right it makes that possible it's
just like workers right you have the the
serialization communication problem
right where it's slow also it's a
nightmare to debug it's gross but let's
check it out come back over here I'll
just show you what I did here real quick
so in here I have a similar kind of
setup where we have this main button and
this was on button I use performance
marks because there's not really UI
involved here so here I just do some
stupid thing where I reduce like a
million things in an array and it was um
I essentially do the same thing but just
in rust here I'm in X dot RS you might
say how I just have rust just chilling
in this folder and it works it's amusing
parcel so if you use parcel you can come
on over here and just import from your
rust file and in the compile it to waz
them and it's usable it's not usually
this there's simple sometimes it's a
little bit tougher if you have it
actually doing anything anything other
than numbers you have to go through a
pretty complicated setup but let's let's
take a look at our performance marks and
see what the difference is all right I'm
gonna come here we're in a record I'm
gonna hit the main thread and I'm gonna
hit waz them then we can take a look
right so they essentially do the same
thing but if we look at our timings
alright to reduce a million things in
regular JavaScript on the main thread
that is going to be 27 milliseconds
which is big and then it'll cause you to
drop a frame you got to use them works
it's the little rascals they're hard to
find
yeah so the Oise on one took 55
microseconds to run so if you want I
mean this is an incredibly contrived
example I've
if I make it in time I have a better
example of using Waze them for something
fun but it's an option all right so if
you wanted to talk about was jank
protection right so you saw we had our
canvas and then we went and put
something in a web worker but you don't
always get to control that you're not
always in a position where the thing
that you're working on you own the whole
chrome of everything right so if you say
hey I have this this time-sensitive
thing right I have something that is a
interruptible right
he needs to animate or it needs to be
shown at a you know like financial data
or something or life if you wait and the
timings off you know lose a billion
dollars or what have you you know you
want to make uninterruptible UI right so
if that UI itself is a candidate for
being displayed in the canvas I have the
coolest thing in the world for you and
that is off-screen canvas you show of
hands who's heard of off-screen canvas
all right all scream canvas is the jam
so it's a canvas that can be drawn off
the main screen all right more
importantly off thread and in a worker
and it lets you create threaded
uninterruptible UI your it's it's
essentially UI threading doesn't work
with the Dom but if you're doing canvas
stuff you can thread your UI it has all
the drawbacks of regular canvas like
accessibility problems it's a little new
so you know browser support and it
glitches a little sometimes but it's
pretty incredible I'm gonna show you the
demo real quick all right so got these
two little rascals jumping up and down
having fun
so in here here's here's where the magic
happens I have wall screen canvas right
here and then I have my canvas and I
transfer control to off-screen so with
your with your canvas you transfer
control to off-screen and then I created
a worker here work rjs and then i
postmessage this canvas right which ii
array is transferable right so it's it
sends this this instance of off-screen
canvas to my worker
inside of my worker right I have this on
requestanimationframe just drawing so
I'm just sending it to canvas and I set
the canvas in scope using that message
back over here right we have a this
event listener where we do the same
thing where we calculate the primes on
80 billion things so this rascal on the
left is a regular canvas the guy on the
right is the off-screen canvas so no
matter what's happening on your main
thread this one keeps going it's like a
little chunk of your screen that just
operates independently so for certain
performance problems and challenging UI
problems this is a candidate to get it
done all right
oh no it's time for the fun demo ok
hopefully this works
you carry a lavalier mic around with me
all the time what is that oh [ __ ] that's
the headphone thing you know the like
with the the Bose headphones it has like
a special little wire it's missing it's
found he's wrapped up on this rascal ok
uh yeah it's probably two minutes
hopefully can make this this work so
[Music]
this
[Music]
okay so before I was talking about how
that was an example is kind of [ __ ]
but there are really cool things that
you can do with wasum that make it worth
it and I wanted to show you one of them
that I did which is silly as can be and
what it is is I took a an auto-tuned
library it was written in C and then I
used M script in write what M scripting
does is take yeah it takes anything that
can be compiled with LLVM and it'll
it'll compile it to azam right so I can
take this this C code here alright and
then I can compile that down to wow them
and run it in our browser thankfully
Google provided this lovely ring buffer
worklet processor so we're running this
in an audio worklet and what it lets you
do is process on a worker thread with
was um a stream of audio right the
problem is is that this thing has a
buffer right which is how much is like
processed at a given time I think it was
like 2048 or something and the audio
worklet is 120 so you need this to
translate the two so I am running out of
time so let's check this out hopefully
this works you
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] crazy right
all right and you could just use import
the module right here the the wasum
module alright you come in here and this
is this is your actual processing method
here so on the web in a worklet in an
audio worklet it goes here and it will
actually process this right then in
there right you have this kernel process
right that's that's how it goes through
but that [ __ ] barely works on some
computers and here here it is working on
the web so waz I'm sick you should check
it out that's all I have on performance
thanks so much for listening to me read
[Applause]